we somehow make the smooth segue to Tom
Curren the Patriots inside her friend BC
sports Boston how's morale in Boston
Tommy I would say because it's cloudy
with a little bit of maybe freezing rain
dropping right now and it canceled
Boston Marathon it's low but I hope that
people people gather there their senses
and and buckle up and move forward
because it's you know suck it up for
three weeks two months and this will be
a chapter in the history of the country
that we made it through
despite maybe a slow start next week Tom
Brady will be with the Patriots with
another team no decision made no
decision made also nothing but what
happens next week with Brady
well I think the free agency is probably
gonna be held off I just think that the
NFL is gonna block at the optics of it
but bottom line he's not gonna come back
here not the way things are trending
right now they had a phone call last
week Belichick and Brady did not go well
Belichick acting as if Brady was still
in the contract they'll Arnold from WEEI
saying that part of that was based
around the fact that Belichick said we
can't pay you more than last year
so when I was told it's acting as if
he's still under contract that makes
sense if that's what he was told because
that's what you tell a guy who doesn't
have any leverage well I wonder about
his leverage no Tom I don't think
they're eight teams interested in Brady
I'm sure there are a couple of teams
that are gonna have to overspend for him
but if you know Tampa it piers is all in
I don't know if Tennessee is I don't
know San Francisco is I don't know if
there's a mystery team here but if if
you're going to look at the odds here
you're playing favorites here who would
you pick well just an aside here I don't
think the level of intensity has to be
the same for every team in order to for
there to be a legitimate interest well I
know but when you say when Jeff
Darlington says eight teams you know
eight teams if I can get him for $17
yeah I mean well it came depending upon
what hoops I need to throw jump through
I think the Niners again with the number
of people who have jumped on that since
Sanders mentioned and Florio mention it
that I mentioned it now Mike Lombardi's
been riding like a mule I think he could
be disabused or really quickly if Kyle
Shanahan felt that was something he
would do it so to me the Niners are an
absolute you know that's a very narrow
hoop to fire through but I think that
there's legitimate interest on the parts
of five or six teams which would be
Chargers definitely Bucs definitely
Raiders perhaps to a degree although I
was told that Gruden is not going to
intensely pursue Brady but if he calls
he'll listen Titans of course and then I
think the Colts are a team that people
have dismissed outwardly but if they're
going to be kicking the tires on Phillip
Rivers and they're not gonna look at
Brady what do we talk to oh I agree I I
said I don't know why the Colts aren't
in on Brady because you got a great
offensive line you got a great coach
great GM you're playing half your games
indoors to me that if I'm Brady that
would be the place that I would I would
want to play for that team maybe I don't
want to play in Indianapolis but I think
that's a nice little soft landing spot
I concur and I think a lot of jams and
protein personnel are lying right now
because they do have answers in-house
and there's two things there if they
don't get Brady and they don't want to
piss off the guy who is there and if
they don't get Brady to get to save face
you know in terms of you know this isn't
what we were going to try and do anyway
so let me get you with this one let me
hit you with this in the final minute
what would Plan B be for the Patriots
Jared Stidham Oh Jared Stidham will
probably be given every opportunity to
win the quarterback job as far as I can
tell I don't think they're going to go
out and spend 15 million dollars on Andy
Dalton carry Brady's thirteen and a half
million dollars and now have 28 and a
half million dollars worth of cap money
on that position to get from Dalton
basically this not that much more than
they can conceivably get from stem for
$800,000 I really think that they would
if Brady does not resign they would be
in the market for five million dollar
quarterbacks as opposed to 15 or 18
million dollars
of Acts and I think Stidham would be
given every opportunity to win the job
it's great to talk to you I'm sure we'll
talk soon I know it was I feel bad that
then I was up against the break and then
I took the phone call and the guy
getting married and like you know I took
away some of your quality time with this
smile going down the aisle okay Thank
You Tommy that's Tom Curren Patriots
insider NBC Sports Boston